sur le site internet d'un important
commerçant d'électronique
bruno est attiré par l'annoncé d'un
ordinateur portable avec écran tactile à
650 dollars au magasin le vendeur
confirmé bruno que cet ordi et des
libyens munis d'un écran tactile et
après son achat bruno à une très
mauvaise surprise contrairement aux
prétentions et du site internet et du
vendeur l'écran de son nouveau portable
n'est pas tactile
quand il communique avec le siège social
de l'entreprise qu on lui demande s'il a
bien lu les notes légales contenues dans
le site internet
il y est écrit que le commerçant se
dégage de toute responsabilité quant à
l'inexactitude de ces annonces s'il veut
son écran tactile
il devrait débourser 250 dollars de plus
sur commerçants à tort je ne sont pas
les notes légal du commerçant qui prime
mais bien la loi sur la protection du
consommateur et la loi est claire
puisque le commerçant à un os il
portable à écran tactile à 650 dollars
il doit le frire à ce prix